miles de ciudadanos respondieron este
domingo al llamado de algunas
organizaciones sociales entre ellas
chalecos México a marchar en distintas
ciudades del país y aquí en la capital
de la república para defender a la
suprema corte de justicia de la nación y
a su presidenta la ministra norma piña
de las constantes y fuertes críticas del
presidente López Obrador y los
seguidores de su partido Morena
se movilizaron desde el Monumento a la
Revolución hasta el Zócalo y ya una vez
en las inmediaciones de la Sede del
poder judicial se registró un conato de
enfrentamiento entre quienes marchaban y
quienes permanecían desde hace más de un
mes en plantón a las puertas de la corte
para exigir la renuncia de los ministros
por considerarlos corruptos tuvo que
intervenir personal de la Secretaría de
Seguridad Ciudadana para impedir que
este enfrentamiento llegara a mayores
esta situación se da Después de semanas
que el presidente López Obrador en sus
conferencias matutinas a dirigido
críticas
al poder judicial luego de los fallos
que ha emitido este en contra de algunas
medidas de gobierno por ejemplo que han
tumbado el Plan B electoral o
recientemente han echado abajo un
decreto mediante el cual el gobierno
pretendía que las obras públicas de
gobierno fueran consideradas de
seguridad nacional y por tanto que da la
reservada la información a raíz de estos
fallos de los ministros López Obrador ha
considerado que el poder judicial está
podrido que los ministros responden a
los intereses de una minoría rapaz y que
son una banda de conservadores por tanto
ha dicho que va a reformar o va a meter
una iniciativa para reformar al poder
judicial y que los ministros sean
electos por vía del voto popular quienes
cuestionan estas medidas del presidente
consideran que lo único que busca el
mandatario es tener una corte a modo
controlada y que no objete sus medidas
de gobierno